[Musik]
ist von uns gegangen ich brauche euch
wohl nicht zu sagen wer ist oder egal
von wo aus ihr euch dieses Video anseht
wer alle wissen von wem die Rede ist und
das ist an sich schon eine überraschende
Sache denn könntet ihr mir sagen wer die
derzeitige Regierung Italiens anführt
oder könntet ihr mir den Namen
irgendeines anderen italienischen
Politikers nennen okay okay ich weiß ihr
seid visualpolitik Zuschauer also werdet
ihr es wohl können aber wie glaubt ihr
würde eine Straßenumfrage ausfallen ich
meine welcher Durchschnittsdeutsche
interessiert sich schon für die Politik
eines dünnen langen Landes bei jenseits
der alten Berlusconi ist jedoch jedem
ein Begriff denn er ist einfach eine
faszinierende Figur viele haben ihn mit
Donald Trump vergleichen wollen aber
wenn der Armen Donald Trump nur so viel
erreicht hätte wie Bellos Conny man
könnte sagen dass ganz Koni aus dem
Nichts heraus die absolute Macht erobert
hat wie kaum ein anderer in der
Geschichte er hat nicht nur die
politische Macht in Italien erobert er
hat auch die Macht der Wirtschaft und in
den Medien an sich gerissen wenn Macht
korrumpiert dann korrumpiert absolute
Macht absolut und kaum jemand
personifiziert diesen Spruch besser als
Berlusconi aber er hat auch seine
positiven Seiten zunächst einmal gibt es
etwas das wir an diesem Mann erkennen
müssen und das offen gesagt
beneidenswert ist seine Energie überlegt
mal wenn uns Kuni starb am 12 juni im
Alter von 86 Jahren er war ein alter
Mann doch nur zwei Jahre vor seinem Tod
ging er mit diesem Video auf tiktok ja
oder egal
keine Ahnung
wir werden an dieser Stelle nicht weiter
auf die Botschaft des Videos eingehen
was ich tun möchte ist dass der Mann in
jeder sieht 84 Jahre alt war als das
Video aufgenommen wurde immerhin fünf
Jahre älter als Joe Biden heute und er
kandidierte wieder bei einer Wahl bei
der eine echte Chance hatte zu gewinnen
ich weiß nicht wie es euch geht aber ich
wünschte ich könnte das Alter von 84
Jahren mit dieser Art von Energie
erreichen aber gut geht es in diesem
Video darum
Berus König zu loben und zu
beweihräuchern natürlich nicht
wenn man über Berlusconi spricht spricht
man über Korruption auf persönliche
Vorteilnahme maßgeschneiderte Gesetze
und ein politisches Erbe das gelinde
gesagt mittelmäßig ist man könnte sagen
dass ein großer Teil der Probleme
Italiens deren es nicht wenige gibt
seine Schuld sind ich nehme an dass die
meisten Nachrufe die ihr zu lesen
bekommt auch brennuss Kunis zahlreiche
Sexskandale und seinem Bunga
bunga-parties erwähnen werden nun wir
werden all das auslassen weil wir uns
auf zwei Dinge konzentrieren werden das
politische und das Geschäftliche Profil
dieses Mannes aber wartet am Ende dieses
Videos werdet ihr genau verstehen warum
dies viel viel spannender und
aufregender ist als alle Bunker Bunker
Skandale zusammengenommen werden muss
Kunis Karriere allein liefert schon so
viel filmreifen Stoff dass Sie aus dem
Staunen nicht mehr herauskommen werdet
nun ja in der Tat gibt es bereits ein
berufskuni bei Open und es ist ein
Meisterwerk loro von Paolo sarentino
äußerst empfehlenswert im Guten wie im
Schlechten hat wenn es Kohle definiert
was Italien heute ist aber nicht nur das
er hat auch die Medienlandschaft Europas
revolutioniert wenn du im Europa der
80er oder 90er Jahre aufgewachsen bist
dann hat Silvio Berlusconi deine
Kindheit geprägt und zwar ohne dass du
es gemerkt hast aber warum kennt
eigentlich jeder silberbarus Kuni was
ist sein politisches Vermächtnis warum
sagen wir das in der Geschäftswelt ein
solcher revolutionär war heute werden
wir all diese Fragen und noch viele
weitere beantworten lass uns aber vorher
noch einen kurzen Hinweis unseres tollen
sponses zu Aufschlag einspielen damit
wir danach sofort ungestört fortfahren
können denn solche Bibl ist ein wirklich
empfehlenswertes und sicheres VPN
welches z.B keinerlei Verbindungsdaten
mit lockt natürlich kann ein Wäsche
private nett vor allem Gefahren schützen
die nicht nach wie vor unsichthalten
lassen und wissen was man tut aber es
stellt hier für ein Werkzeug gleich
mehreren Vorteil da zum einen erschwert
ist ein Kombination mit anderen
Vorkehrungen eure Aktionen und abzuhören
mit Hilfe verschiedener Sicherheit könnt
ihr so ähnliche erhöhen z.B mit dem
integriertes alle unerwünscht weitere
Vorteil eines dass sie so tun könnte als
wäre dir in einem anderen Ort suchen zum
Beispiel auf Webseite und
Internetdienste zugreifen im Lande mir
gerade seit den verfügbar wären ob
daheim oder im Urlaub damit schlagt
jetzt Zensur und gioblocking ein
Schnäppchen Netflix und anderes
anbieten von Europa ausnutzen oder
deutsches Internetfernsehen im Ausland
gucken mit surfshark kein Problem aber
das ist noch lange nicht alles denn wenn
nur einem Surfer konnte wirklich alle
eure Endgeräte EVP registrieren Handys
Notebooks oder sogar euren Smart TV so
und wenn ihr den Rabattcode Politik die
angeht bekommt ihr sonst Samstag auch
noch ein Rabatt in Höhe von 83% und
obendrein die ersten drei Monate gratis
dazu den Link zu diesem Angebot findet
ihr in der Beschreibung unter diesem
Video also nichts besonderes damit auch
gleichzeitig uns finanzieren unter die
Arme das könnte übrigens auch direkt mit
Hilfe des Spenden Links die ich euch
ebenfalls in die Videobeschreibung
gepackt habe wir sind euch für jede
Unterstützung danke uns euch in Zukunft
noch mehr und noch bessere Videos zu
liefern so und nun lasst uns aufbrechen
wir begeben uns auf eine Reise nach
Bella Italia wo willst du Beantwortung
unserer Fragen wieso oft zunächst einen
schnellen Blick in die Geschichte werfen
werden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der erste Unterschied zwischen
berluscoli und Donald Trump ist ihre
Herkunft wir haben Donald in eine
Familie hineingeboren wurde die bereits
immens Reich war war Silvio der Spross
einer total durchschnittlichen
Mittelstandsfamilie in Mailand normale
Eltern normale Bildung und ein normales
Leben doch Silvio hatte etwas ganz
Besonderes er war fasziniert vom
Showgeschäft der beste Verkäufer den man
weit und breit finden konnte tatsächlich
startete seine Karriere als reinrassiger
Entertainer Schlagersänger auf Partys
Kreuzfahrten und so weiter natürlich
begann hier auch seine Karriere als
Frauenschwarm aber wie gesagt wir werden
uns nicht auf das Sexleben eines
Politikers konzentrieren denn wir sind
ein seriöserkanal nicht wahr tatsache
ist aber das Verlusten indem er die
Meilen der Nächte belebte Kontakte
knüpfte um sein erstes großes
Geschäftsprojekt zu starten Milano Duo
ein Megaprojekt mit 4000 Wohnungen es
sollte ein durchschlagender
wirtschaftlicher Erfolg werden unter uns
zu einem reichen Geschäftsmann machen
aber täuscht euch nicht was bei uns Kuni
wirklich interessierte war nicht der
Immobilienmarkt sondern die Medien
berufskolle ist Doktorarbeit befasst
sich nämlich mit dem Werbegeschäft in
den Medien eine Arbeit hier übrigens mit
Soma cum laudeabschluss so dumm wie
viele glauben kann er also nicht gewesen
sein in der Tat müssen wir in diesen
frühen Jahren seiner Karriere eines
erkennen er war ein ziemlich großer
Visionär und wieso das werdet ihr jetzt
gleich erfahren
der Pate des Privatfernsehens
auch wenn viele sich dies nicht mehr
vorstellen können es gab eine Zeit in
der Privatfernsehen in den meisten
europäischen Ländern verboten war und
nein wir sprechen ja nicht vom Ostblock
in den 1970er Jahren stand das Fernsehen
in Italien und anderen Ländern wie
Deutschland Frankreich und Spanien unter
einem staatlichen bzw
öffentlich-rechtlichen Monopol das heißt
wenn man in Italien den Fernseher
einschaltete konnte man nur die Kanäle
Erreichen der italienischen
öffentlich-rechtlichen Fernsehanstalt
empfangen damit ihr euch eine
Vorstellung davon machen könnt 1973
erließ die italienische Regierung eine
Kredit dass sie jeden Versuch verboten
ein privaten Fernsehsender zu gründen
sie hatten nämlich nicht nur ein Monopol
auf das Fernsehen sondern auch auf die
Fernsehwerbung und das war ein sehr sehr
lukratives Geschäft wer muss Colin war
sich dessen bewusst und deshalb war es
ein Ziel dieses Monopol zu brechen und
sein eigenes nationales Fernsehen zu
haben die Frage ist wie hat er das
geschafft nun passt jetzt gut auf denn
diese Geschichte wäre wahrlich eines
eigenen visualpolitikvideos würde ich
die erste Frage stellen müssen lautet
warum war das Fernsehen ein Monopol nun
zum einen aus technischen Gründen wegen
des begrenzten funkspektrums
[Musik]
damals gab es noch kein digitales
Fernsehen geschweige denn das Internet
das Fernsehen wurde im Vergleich zu
heute eher über langweilige
Funkfrequenzen übertragen und deren Zahl
ist nun mal begrenzt mit anderen Worten
es gab nicht unendlich viele Frequenzen
für alle die Fernsehen ausstrahlen
wollten natürlich gab es auch politische
Gründe aber zu dieser Zeit kam eine neue
Technologie für die TV-Übertragung auf
okay okay das Kabelfernsehen bot
genügend Kapazitäten für die Übertragung
mehrerer Fernsehkanäle das Problem nicht
alle Häusern Italien waren für den
Empfang vorbereitet außer die Häuser von
Milano Duell
[Applaus]
ganz genau berluscoli hatte dafür
gesorgt dass eine 4000 Haushalte mit
Kabelfernsehen ausgestattet wurden nach
einem langen Rechtsstreit erlaubte das
italienische Verfassungsgericht die
Einrichtung privater Fernsehsender die
über Kabel senden zumindest solange dies
nur auf lokaler Ebene geschieht
berauskoli hatte zu diesem Zeitpunkt
4000 Haushalte die Zuschauer eines
eigenen Fernsehens werden konnten und so
wurde Tele Milano geboren ein
Fernsehsender der nicht einmal regional
Fernsehen war er war ein
stadtviertelsender natürlich war Tele
Milano nicht das einzige Lokal Fernsehen
das über Kabel ausgestrahlt wurde aber
es war eines der beliebtesten denn es
hatte den direkten Draht zu immerhin
4.000 Haushalten was gut und gerne 10
bis 12000 des öffentlich rechtlichen
Monopol bereits überdrüssige Zuschauer
auf einen Schlag waren aber wartet eine
Sekunde denn das war erst der Anfang
zwei Jahre später 1976 entschied des
Verfassungsgericht erneut über die Frage
der privaten Fernsehsender diesmal
erlaubte privaten Fernsehsender über
Funkfrequenzen zusenden solange sie nur
lokal sendeten mit anderen Worten man
durfte einen Fernseh in Mailand Turin
oder Rom betreiben aber keinen der
landesweit sendete und was glaubt ihr
hat Berlusconi zu diesem Zeitpunkt getan
nun der gute alte Silvio kaufte einfach
alle lokalen Fernsehsender in allen
Regionen Italiens auf innerhalb weniger
Jahre Übernahme er Roma TV Video Veneto
teletorino im Grunde gelang es ihm alle
privaten Fernsehsender des Landes zu
übernehmen er vereinte sie zu Italiens
ersten großen Medienkonzernen 1981
endeten all diese lokalen Fernsehsender
ihr Logo in ein einheitliches Kanal
auf diese Weise erreichte der das was
zuvor unmöglich schien das
öffentlich-rechtliche fernsehmonopol zu
knacken er war quasi aus eigener Kraft
zu einem medialen Kartellwächter
geworden um dem italienischen Volk
endlich landesweit medialen Wettbewerb
und Vielfalt zu bringen und ja er wurde
ein verdammt harter Konkurrenz Imperiums
dank seines nationalen fernsehennetzes
kommt der kanalaging für die
beliebtesten öffentlichen Fernsehstars
unter Vertrag nehmen so verließ der
berühmte Mike und journey die öffentlich
rechtliche Anstalt und wechselte zum
brandneuen Privatfernsehen die Strategie
hätte nicht aggressiver sein können er
muss Conny wollte den ganzen Markt
verschlingen und dafür sollte er keine
Kosten er kaufte die beliebtesten Serien
aus den USA und brachte sogar japanische
Anime in die italienischen Haushalte so
steht der Umsatz von Canale Schinkel
allein zwischen 1980 und 81 von 13
Milliarden Tiere auf mehr als 75
Milliarden Jahre 1987 hatte da los Kunis
Fernsehen bereits einen Marktanteil von
48% im ganzen Land
[Musik]
und falls ihr an dieser Stelle noch
immer nicht aus dem Staunen herauskommen
solltet ihr euch bei gegenwärtigen dass
nur 15 Jahre zuvor privates lernen in
Italien nicht einmal gesetzlich erlaubt
war was für eine wilde Fahrt und dass
ich die Verhältnisse so schnell ändern
konnten war ein erster Linie Berlusconis
Verdienst er war der große und Vorreiter
des Privatfernsehens ein medialer
visionär und revolutionär nicht nur in
Italien sondern ganz Europa denn sein
Erfolg ist eine Welle von Nachahmer nach
der anderen in den übrigen europäischen
Ländern mit sich aber falls ihr dachtet
dass seine geschäftskarriere damit an
ihrem Höhepunkt angekommen war dann
liegt ihr vollkommen falsch nach seiner
Eroberung Italiens ging Silvio weiter um
Europa nicht nur indirekt zu verändern
sondern direkt zu erobern so entstand
die Mediaset Group die noch heute einer
der größten Medienkonzerne Europas Essen
im Grunde widmet er sich Verluste König
von da an dem Kopf von Anteil an vielen
privaten Fernsehsendern den anderen
Ländern um ihn herum entstanden ein
prominentes Beispiel ist Spanien bis
1989 war das Privatfernsehen auch in
Spanien verboten aber in den 1990er
Jahren bereiteten die Regierung dem
öffentlichen Monopol ein Ende Silvio
auch bekannt als il Cavaliere stand
natürlich schon mit seinen Fuß in der
Tür um telesingko zu übernehmen telecin
sollte in den 90er Jahren zu dem
prägenden Fernsehsender für eine ganze
Generation von Spanien werden in
Deutschland engagierte sich Berlusconi
erst recht spät mit dem Einstieg bei
Gericht Media dem damaligen Eigentümer
von ProSieben Sat.1 kabel eins und DSF
mit dem Münchner Medienunternehmen Leo
Kirch hatte er schon seit den 1990er
Jahren zusammengearbeitet die
vollständige Übernahme seiner Firma
schattete jedoch schließlich am
Widerstand der deutschen Medienaufsicht
und okay manche mögen sagen das mit
Berlusconis Sender nur Trash TV und
Sensationslust in die Wohnstuben Einzug
hielt aber niemand kann Leute denn das
ist ein vorher und ein nachher gab was
das Verständnis der Medien angeht und
dann dieser sowieso schon Kontroversen
Stelle kommen wir zum dunkelsten Teil
von Berlusconis Geschäft Karriere
nämlich den Schulden
[Musik]
ein solches Medienimperium baut man
nicht in etwas mehr als 10 Jahren auf
ohne sich bei der halben Welt Geld zu
leihen im Jahr 1994 war Finn Invest der
Final zweigte Imperiums das am
zweithöchsten verschuldete Unternehmen
in Italien tja und an diesem Punkt
angekommen was glaubt ihr was er getan
hat was ist der nächste Schritt wenn man
Herr und Meister der Medien geworden ist
nun man packt seine Sachen und verlässt
das Unternehmen ja ihr habt richtig
gehört im Jahr 1994 packte Berlusconi
seine spricht wirklich ein Schreibtisch
Utensilien in den ebenfalls
sprichwörtlichen Pappkarton und gab alle
seine Führungspositionen auf aber er
behielt alle Anteile an seinem Imperium
er brauchte es noch für etwas anderes
viel viel größeres aufgepasst denn erst
jetzt wird es richtig spannend das
politische Imperium
die italienische Politik ist ein echter
Wahnsinn und es spielt keine Rolle zu
welchen Zeitpunkt wir auf sie blicken es
gilt einfach für jeden beliebigen
Zeitraum der italienischen Geschichte in
diesem Land halten die
Ministerpräsidenten im Durchschnitt zwei
einhalb Jahre durch falls ihr die
italienische Politik studiert werdet ihr
auf die alle verrücktesten Stories
stoßen Verschwörungen durch geheimlosen
Staat Terrorismus und natürlich mafias
aller cooler von denen die Parteien und
der Staaten nur so durchsetzt sind in
all diesen Chaos gab es jahrzehntelang
nur eine konstante die Christdemokraten
wir sprechen von einer
mittelrechtspartei die das Land während
des gesamten Kalten Kriegs beherrschte
aber 1994 löste sich die
Christdemokratie durch eine Spirale von
korruptionskandalen die einer Banane
Republik würde ich wären praktisch
vollständig auf die rechte insgesamt war
verwüstet und die Linke konnte die
heimatlos gewordenen konservativen
Wähler nicht überzeugen aber wo ist
Leute gibt die kaufen wollen gibt es
auch jemanden der verkaufen will und wer
weiß besser als jeder andere wie man
verkauft ganz genau Silvio berlus Koni
in den Noten der 80er Jahren hatte er
noch öffentlich die Sozialistische
Partei unterstützt aber jetzt wusste er
dass er die Seiten wechseln musste wenn
er Wahlen gewinnen wollte und so
gründete er seine eigene bitte rechts
Partei obwohl na ja eigentlich handelt
es sich eher um eine Partei ohne
Ideologie im Grunde verliebt der Prozess
folgendermaßen was mögen die Italiener
mehr als Pizza und Frauen genau Fußball
und was rufen Italiener wenn Sie Ihre
Nationalmannschaft anfeuern Forza Italia
Bingo da hätten wir also schon mal den
Namen unter dem gespielt wird tja und
was ist mit der ideologischen
Ausrichtung nun das ist ganz einfach wir
sind für das Gute und gegen das
schlechte wer würde nicht für eine
solche Partei stimmen wollen und auf
diese Weise hat Verluste 94 ausgerechnet
im Jahr der Fußball Weltmeisterschaft
die parteivor Zeit Italia gegründet
[Musik]
ich brauche euch wohl nicht zu sagen
dass balloscoli noch im selbia die
Wahlen gewonnen hat aber wir wären hier
nicht bei visualpolitik wenn wir diesen
Erfolg alleine durch einen knackigen
Namen und einen geschmeidigen Slogan
erklären würden ganz und gar nicht das
war nur die Kosmetik die waren drei
Gründe waren die folgenden erstens hatte
er die Kontrolle über den größten
Fernsehsender des Landes zweitens die
anderen Parteien liquidierten sich quasi
gegenseitig oder selbst durch interne
Streitigkeiten und drittens haben wir es
mit der charismatischsten Persönlichkeit
zu tun die es je gab und deren Präsenz
die Italiener dank seiner medialen
Dominanzen und nirgendwo mehr entkommen
konnten und auf diese Weise begann die
beeindruckendste politische Karriere in
der Geschichte des modernen Italien denk
bitte daran das ist das Chaos ist das
die italienische Politik regiert und das
legte natürlich auch für beruskonie
keine verstauchpause ein es Finger an
sich zu räumen deswegen war er zwar von
Noten 94 bis 2011 Ministerpräsident aber
in mehreren unterbrochenen Perioden
zuerst vor letzten Jahr dann für fünf
und dann noch mal für drei trotzdem kann
man sagen dass er uns Kone der Politiker
ist der Italien am längsten regiert hat
und wir können vor allem auch sagen dass
er der Regierungschef mit der größten
Macht war denn er hat nicht nur die
Politik sondern zeitgleich auch die
Medien kontrolliert so kontrollierte er
Schätzungen von The Economist zufolge im
Jahr 2001 91% der italienischen
Fernsehbildschirme aber nicht etwa weil
seine Privatsender die
Öffentlich-Rechtlichen niedergeweicht
hätten nein letzter hielten nach wie vor
stark gemacht Anteile viel mehr war
beruskunes Medi alle Dominanz das
Ergebnis einer skrupellosen eines
demokratischen Landes unwürdigen
Gleichschaltung des Kampagnen bei Reihe
stellt euch das folgendermaßen vor er
besaß Canale Schinken und beherrschte
durch seinen maßlosen politischen
Einfluss gleichzeitig das öffentlich
rechtliche Fernsehen das Fazit der Mann
der in den 1980er Jahren das staatliche
fernsehmonopol beendet hatte baute
schließlich ein weiteres viel brutaleres
Monopol auf und hier kommen wir zum
dunkelsten Teil seines Lebens
[Musik]
denn wenn Macht korrumpiert dann
korrumpiert absolute Macht eben absolut
und berusconi machte das Parlament zu
seinem Hinterhof den Staat zu seinem
Privatbesitz seine
gleichschaltungsventilität machte bei
den Medien keinen Halt sondern
erstreckte sich über Legislative und
Exekutive bis in die Judikative er ließ
schlicht und einfach Gesetze
verabschieden die auf seine persönlichen
und privaten Bedürfnisse zugeschnitten
waren zum Beispiel gerade in Italien
2004 ein Gesetz in Kraft dazu Pension
für den Kauf von Digital TV dann vorsah
und wem gehörte das größte Unternehmen
dass diese Geräte verkaufte genau
Familie aber das ist wahrlich du die
Spitze des gigantischen verlustonischen
Korruptions Eisbergs die Liste ist
England steueramlistin
Finanzvorschriften zum Wohle eines
Mannes er versuchte zahlreichen
korruptions-prozessen zu entkommen man
kann sagen dass Silvio beresconi das
italienische Staatswesen an sich selbst
privatisiert hat Italien nach seinen
Interessen verändert hat
[Musik]
so weit so schlecht aber kommen wir nun
zum wichtigsten dem Gesamtbild welches
politische Erbe hinterlässt Berus Kuni
abgesehen von der Korruption war er eher
gut für Italiener oder eher schlecht und
das werden wir jetzt mal lieber ganz
genau unter die Lupe nehmen aufgepasst
[Musik]
macht um der Macht willen
jetzt wo ihr einen Einblick in die
politische Klasse Italiens bekommen habt
glaubt ihr wahrscheinlich schlimmer
geht's nimmer aber weit gefehlt in
Italiens Wirtschaft herrscht nämlich
noch ein übleres Chaos aber Achtung
eigentlich hat der Italien in den 1980er
Jahren eine sehr gute Zeit als beruskuli
sein Wirtschaftsimperium Aufbau der
erlebte das Land seine wirtschaftliche
Blütezeit italienisches Design Autos
Mode und ja auch maschinentechnische
Produkte und vieles andere made in Italy
war auf der ganzen Welt in und die
Export Erlöse flossen nur so in die
Kassen südlich der Alpen Anfang der
1990er Jahre waren die Italiener
schließlich reicher als die Briten und
kurz davor mit den deutschen gleich zu
ziehen heute aber ist Italien der kranke
Mann Europas eines der wenigen Länder
das heute ärmer ist als vor 20 Jahren
und warum werdet ihr euch fragen wie
konnte es nur so weit kommen nun wir
haben schon ein paar ziemlich
aufschlussreiche Videos gedreht in denen
wir die italienische Misere erklären
sowohl auf wieso hat Politik als auch
economic natürlich werde ich sie
verlinken denn ihr solltet sie euch auf
keinen Fall entgehen lassen falls ihr
wirklich wissen wollt wie die
italienische Wirtschaft tickt an dieser
Stelle nur so viel Italien hat
gravierendes systemische Probleme die es
dem Land fast unmöglich machen zu
funktionieren es hat einen riesigen
völlig ineffizienten staatsapparaten
mehr als 3 Millionen Beamten und
vollkommen aufgeblähte überflüssige
öffentliche Ausgaben aber das ist noch
nicht alles eine der großen Schwächen
Italiens ist die absurdeste Bürokratie
die man sich nur vorstellen kann diese
ist nicht nur überflüssig sondern
geradezu kafkaeske und schädlich z.B
werden fast alle Berufe wie Zünfte
reguliert selbst wenn man als Journalist
oder Informatiker arbeiten möchte
braucht man eine Lizenz und um diese
Lizenz zu bekommen muss man einfach
fahren durchlaufen das aus einer anderen
zeitzustammen scheint wir konnten diese
Universität selbst miterleben als wir
hier bei visualpolitik eine Zeit lang
mit einer italienisches skriptautorin
zusammengearbeitet haben diese Autoren
wollte eine Journalisten Lizenz erwerben
damit sie auch Texte verfassen kann die
in ihrer Heimat veröffentlicht werden um
die Lizenz zu bekommen musste sie
Medienerfahrung nachweisen doch für die
italienischen Bürokraten ist die Arbeit
bei einem großen erfolgreichen
YouTube-Kanal keine Medienerfahrung
neulandeben laut den italienischen
Behörden zählt ein YouTube-Kanal mit
Millionen von Abonnenten nicht zu den
Medien und zwar aus Gründen auf jeden
Fall wurde ihr die Lizenz in Italien
versagt so dass Italiener auf die
Früchte ihrer journalistischen Arbeit
verzichten müssen wo kämen wir denn auch
hin wenn einfach jeder seine Ergebnisse
und das Volk bringen könnte ohne
Erlaubnis erhabenen Politiker und
Beamten nun denn all diesen Problemen
zum Trotz wuchs Italiens Wirtschaft in
den 80er Jahren und ihr werdet euch
sicher fragen wieso eigentlich was war
das Geheimnis des italienischen
Wirtschaft bzw Export Wunder damals
waren es geniale Erfindungen gewieftes
Marketing und widerstehliches Design die
attraktive Ausstrahlung der
italienischen deutsche Vita nun
vielleicht spielte sowas auch eine
gewisse Rolle der Hauptgrund der den
Ausschlag gab war aber ein viel
profanera
Italien war süchtig nach Abwertung die
wertete die Lira mehrfach massiv ab um
die italienischen Produkte auf den
internationalen Märkten billiger zu
machen eine gigantische dumping
Strategie Falle ganze Volkswirtschaft
und diese Strategie ging voll und ganz
auf in den 80er 90er Jahren war made in
Italy in ganz Europa auf dem Vormarsch
doch diese Erfolgsstory sollte in den
2000er Jahren einiges Ende finden die
abwertungsstrategie Roms wurde durch
gleich zwei voneinander unabhängige
historischen Großereignisse gnadenlos
durchkreuzt na kommt ihr drauf welche
dies waren ganz genau erstens hat China
damals der Welthandelsorganisation bei
und zweitens Italien dem Euro das
Ergebnis mit den noch billigeren Preisen
der chinesischen Unternehmen konnten
Italiener nicht konkurrieren und ihre
Währung konnten sie auch nicht mehr
abwerten die Kombination dieser beiden
geoökonomischen Veränderungen löste eine
lange Krise aus aus der Italien bis
heute nicht herausgekommen ist aber
kommen wir zurück zum Protagonisten
unseres Videos
konnte die Krise scheinbar nichts
anhaben denn sein einziges Ziel war nur
Wahlen gewinnen
[Applaus]
dieses Lied war der wahlsport mit dem
erlusculi 2008 die Wahlen erneut gebannt
es gab kein Italiener der nicht schon
eine Million Mal gehört hat ich empfehle
euch sich mal den Songtext durchzulesen
der bringt sein Wahlprogramm perfekt auf
den Punkt für das Gute und gegen das
schlechte denn was wollten die Italiener
eigentlich nun die Illusion aufrecht
erhalten das ist im Grunde keine
Probleme gibt das nichts reformiert
werden muss und das alles gut gehen wird
die staatlichen Wohltaten beibehalten
werden die Wirtschaft den Bach
runtergeht egal ob man es sich leisten
kann oder nicht das ist etwas da muss
Kuni immer versprochen und auch erreicht
hat und die Quittung für diese Politik
sieht dann so aus hier könnt ihr einen
Augenschein nehmen wie beruskonie
Italien auf dieser Beweise geführt hat
wie seine eigenen Unternehmen durch das
auf Türmen gegen gigantischer
Schuldenberge nach Silvio kann immer die
Sinnflut
[Musik]
derzeit steht Italien im Verhältnis zum
BIP auf Platz 7 und in Bezug auf die pro
Kopf Verschuldung auf Platz 5 der Welt
Rangliste der am tiefsten verschuldeten
Staaten mit anderen Worten wenn Italien
schon vorwerbungsprobleme hatte so hat
es jetzt ein zusätzliches Problem die
Schuldenspirale heute ist Italien eines
der größten Problemländer Europas und
daran trägt einen gewaltigen Teil der
Schuld das heutige Italien ist das
Ergebnis dessen was besonders getan oder
besser nicht getan hat und das obwohl er
mehr Macht besaß als fast jeder andere
Politiker
[Musik]
aber was hat Berlusconi eigentlich so in
den letzten Jahren getrieben nun die
Wahrheit ist dass er die Politik nie
aufgegeben hat wie wir eingangs gesehen
haben hat er sich auch im Alter von 84
Jahren noch zur Wahl gestellt allerdings
können wir kaum eine nennenswerte
politische Position hervorheben außer
dieser eigenen
extrem verteidigt Russland Krieg am
Vorabend der Wahl in Italien der
ehemalige italienische Ministerpräsident
Vladimir Putins einmal in der Ukraine
verteidigt und gesagt dass der russische
staatsche in den Konflikt hineingedrängt
wurde der 85-Jährige sagte die
russischen Truppen sollten die Regierung
der Ukraine durch anständige Leute
ersetzen und dann abziehen der
dreimalige italienische Premierminister
ist ein langjähriger Verbündeter des
russischen Präsidenten ganz genau
berlusconi hat Russland im Krieg gegen
die Ukraine unterstützt und warum um
Himmels willen werdet ihr euch jetzt
fragen ist der Ideologie frei
Opportunist auf seine alten Tage etwa zu
einem waschechten Neonazi mutiert nun
sein Argument basiert allein auf der
Tatsache dass er Wladimir Putin
persönlich kennt und sie sehr gute
Freunde sind in diesem Fall scheint so
als ob Balance Kunis Privatleben seine
politischen Position vollkommen
überlagert hat oder so wie es auf Fotos
wie diesen aussieht
unser Fazit niemand kann leugnen das
Balance Kuni ein wahres Genie war ein
Selfmade-Man er hat es geschafft mehr
Macht anzuhäufen als fast jeder andere
Mann der jüngeren Geschichte vielleicht
eben mit Ausnahme seines busenkumpels
Putin er hat wirtschaftliche politische
und mediale macht in einer Person
vereint allerdings musste dieser überaus
überragenden Mann all seine Macht sobald
er sie vereinnahmt hatte auf eine
gelinde gesagt er mittelmäßige Weise und
für sein Volk eben auf eine eher
schädliche und destruktive zum Glück war
dabei aber noch Lichtjahre entfernt von
seinem Freund Putin eine kriegerische
Wiedererrichtung des römischen Reiches
mit der er das italienische folgt dann
ist absolute verderben gerissen hätte
kam dem ehemaligen Schlagersänger mit
autokratischen Anwendungen dann doch
nicht mehr in den Sinn Bunga Bunker hat
ihn gereicht und bum bum war nicht mehr
nötig die Italiener sind noch mal mit
einem blauen Auge und einem Schuldenberg
davongekommen trotzdem eine derartige
Akkumulation sowohl medianer als auch
politischer Macht sollte in einer
Demokratie ausgeschlossen sein baroscoli
hat dadurch Europa vor Augen geführt wie
zart und zerbrechlich Demokratie auch in
einem scheinbar modernen und
aufgeklärten Land sein kann dass sie
alles andere als als verständlich ist
und jede anständige Mensch täglich für
Sie kämpfen muss aber jetzt kommt die
Fragen erstmal an euch werden denn
Europa jemals wieder einen neuen
staatsche mit so viel Macht wie
balusconi erleben gibt es andere
internationale Staatschefs die sich mit
il Cavalieri vergleichen können hat er
durch seine Nähe zu Putin am Ende seines
Lebens die letzten Reste seiner
Glaubwürdigkeit verspielt und werdet ihr
mit 80 Jahren auch noch so viel Energie
haben wie Silvio wie immer sind auf eure
Diskussion zu diesem Thema schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht
auch etwas dabei gelernt habt falls ja
geht ihm ein Like und teilt es mit euren
Freunden und ist mit ihnen auch
ausgiebig zu diskutieren vergessen bitte
auch nicht das Abo mit Glöckchen wenn
euch unser Kanal gefällt natürlich
freuen uns doch jederzeit über eine
Spende von euch dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
in der Beschreibung unter dem Video
macht's gut bis bald und wieder
[Musik]